man a bunch of Star Wars stuff happened
last week if you didn't notice that then
you were probably not on the internet
for an entire week one of the things we
saw was star wars battlefront or kind of
saw Chris and Rob you guys were his this
expression is kind of what what I was
surely that's what happens when Rob goes
all the way to anaheim to check out star
wars battlefront when you guys didn't
really see much no saw more than you
guys did that's true so what did we see
we saw this like you saw a trailer that
was like been injured in engine so cool
right in engine so that was you know
that teased a bunch of stuff but what we
saw was like a 78 minute gameplay demo
that was a runt that was pre-recorded on
a pre-alpha ps4 okay that was the that
was a thing but it was actual gameplay
it was like on the forest moon of Endor
your rebel soldier you're switching
between the 1st and 3rd person view sort
of making your way towards the center of
the battle scripted in the way that like
any battlefield es game has to be
scripted in the press scenario because
otherwise it's like this was shooting
together all the right this was not
single player Oh was so was imagined to
be multiplayer but you could okay all
most considerate single-player and like
that if I were to be playing against
computer hey I like maybe that it was a
demo of the multiplayer right yeah and
they all had like all that all the
characters had little like blue or red
names or their heads to digital I don't
know if the bots would do that there is
a single player mode you can play its
missions that are just like set within
the multiplayer area but cool like I
just meant it was only 42 in Vietnam
stuff II I guess I don't really play
Vietnam I guess what sort of its there's
still so much speculation like all right
I've got some questions that we can like
it rhymed us at let's do yes did the
gameplay look anything like the in
engine stuff that they showed us the
event no like in terms of quality I mean
I will say like like positive like the
takeaways is that it looked awesome does
it look and look like this no it did not
look like it looks it did not look this
good this is like the lighting is much
more polished on this the obviously the
troop movements here but when
I mean from my perspective yeah it
didn't look this good but it did look
good like when they did that pan down in
and they did that pan down during the
gameplay and like the bark on the trees
the light on the trees the ferns on the
forest floor the like needles on the
forest floor all this was catching my
eye and giving me a very strong newer
woods vibe that's a redwood park in the
bay area that's where they filmed these
scenes like that's where they went to
like take the images it was eye-catching
so I definitely what did you see in the
game today then what was going on what
was happening so one thing was like you
just saw the dome shield yeah what we
saw was not I mean I'm sure there's a
shield that you can throw down for many
people to use but at one moment you're
looking across you see all your soldiers
wearing their own individual shield they
have a personal just like a bubble
shield yeah right another moment you
look up and you know like the Ewok force
they have like the walkways and bridge
and stuff so you look up and you see
like a storm troopers like sniper and he
was in a beam laser sniper right like it
that was pretty cool he takes out a
couple guys in front of you you keep
walking one of my favorite parts was
like the whole forest seemed so open
like yes there probably are a couple of
like push pass and stuff like that but
you could just kind of segue off
anywhere go like take cover behind any
redwood trees there are a lot of trees
and yeah one point like two speeder
bikes like zoom by in the chase which
was cool but no recently what the hell
are these guys even doing like you
looking it looked like a Raceway track
around the whole map so all these guys
are doing or just booking it around a
circle you can imagine like are these
guys are you really need contributing to
combat or are you just joyriding like
jets in a battlefield match yeah I don't
know that sort of remained to be seen
there was no pot no piloting of vehicles
in the demo of the dude was on foot the
whole time they took down an eight EST
with like light arms fire in the trailer
you see them take it down with a rocket
but this was just like sustained like
blaster fire took down yeah it's a CST
any jet packs I think there was one
there but it looked more like a jump
pack like it's not a jet pack in the
sense that like thrust yeah it's just a
thruster pack kind of thing so that was
good so Rob I was talking to you after
you got in and you said that the time
when they took it was it not out or an
eight EST when they 8080 right but it
was a it was a straight-up like quick
time event yeah it was such a buzzkill
lately show you
you you take out the stsci you see down
the path they do a cool zoom in with a
scope and you see the foot right and
then you look up you're like holy God
here it is and it's big the sound design
was awesome so these things just dice
the sound design yeah is so good like
it's laying down like on your troops so
you all you do is you cross the river
and then there's just like uplink and if
you can imagine like this is where
people are fighting for early are you
defending as the storm troopers or
you're attacking so you go up to the
side it looks like it's like where do
you check your email in the forest it
was turkey utterly a chill up like half
the size of this desk all right great
here it is like why am I even going here
why this dude what happens you just go
up a hold square you activate it and
then why winks coming in and you look up
and you see why wings fly by over the
treetops you're like alright cool and
then they even go as far as like oh it's
crazy up here Huawei's under fire whirl
we'll be back hang in there and then
you're just now you're walking around
you're like alright so does it fold out
eventually but what's so frustrating is
like so why wings are whatever the hell
they're doing up there and you're
walking around and then you see these 80
80 and you're walking underneath the
belly of it looking up and it's sweet
and you think why can't I pull a Luke
Skywalker and shoot a grapa get up there
and just just mess it up likes mess up
right cuz you're Joe rebel man you can't
do that stuff I guess not and so then
you walk way and then finally here we
come okay right then the y-wings take it
down and you're like cool so obviously
the demo is scripted but like I think
that situation is Walker assault is
there like one is basically the only one
of the only new modes they even mention
Ryan so a walker going through the
forest like that's not going to be a fun
driving experience yeah right there's a
penny arcade comic that's just like yep
like you know you could get stuck
between trees and is like being a peep
uh so I think that in Walker assault it
seems like it's sort of a tiered thing
we're like okay you know the rebels have
to that the the Empire has to force the
rebels back enough so that they can have
the Walker gain entrance but then that's
a new phase of the battle and the
walkers like walking in there this is
all speculation by the way on my part
Walker's like someone's in the turret
blasting and then like the stormtroopers
are defend
the uplinks and then maybe something is
happening in the atmospheric layer that
delayed the y-wings maybe that's the
other team has some kind of input there
yeah but it seems just like a like a
team fortress tug-of-war looks like it's
gonna go this way it's going to go that
way till they're going to stop them
before they get to this checkpoint kind
of thing but they did not offer any
details about that but what is clear and
just yet even like a Don is you you do
take out the 8080 and I didn't show this
in the trailer but then you open up a
bunker door so it's like maybe this is
the last push right yeah you know get in
there and drop the depth charges
wherever it is and you get in and then
of course there's you see like a rebel
soldier like get thrown around and it's
sort later oh cool please walk around
doing it then it's like a destiny styled
boss fight where it's like 20 people all
shooting Darth Vader's which I kind of
how old battlefront games were didn't
get your hero character come in and it
was like oh we got a friggin boat
they'll Boba Fett run around over here
or whatever and it would they become a
magnet because they were so strong do
you think they're gonna do that we're
like one person almost like that book
that the officer class or whatever we're
like one person just gets to be like
yeah but there's gonna be some kind of
spawn mechanic that the obviously you
know can't you're not gonna have like 15
Boba Fett's running around against 15
han Solo does that'll be in the modded
version yeah which will come at about a
month later yeah they're gonna do their
hero character thing and yeah still
there's a ton of the remains to be seen
about sort of how it's going about but
the whole take away from the press event
was like hey you guys remember what
battlefront is this is battlefront right
it's like the school game set in the
Star Wars universe and it is like and it
looked good and there was a lot of
scenes that were like this would be fun
to do look closely they look like they
do ripon with the x-wing through can you
imagine that that would be dope but like
so then here's here's another like hero
system right is like you'd get to be the
Millennium Falcon cool the excited for
it or were you like at this point about
a demo or it it's felt like slightly a
waste of time but just because we didn't
get to see as much as like I wanted yeah
and again speculation like we're still
pondering on what the hell this Walker
battle is even about yeah it was real
early oh yeah it also kind of made me
think like all right I had some I
definitely had fun with battlefront
games back in the day but
like the last bike pc battlefront game
was out in like what 2005-2006 it's been
like a decade you haven't games about
this craziness I systems have come out
in terms of like what makes a shooter
great and you know dice certainly has
their finger on the pulse of a lot of
that stuff but i was thinking cuz all
right in the demo they did this thing
where you come over a ridge and there's
like these just stormtroopers like
they're walking down a stream bed like
on a patrol yeah like no one's doing
that in a multiplayer match there's no
one on patrol they're dummies and you
shoot them like they're dumb
stormtroopers in the movie right so but
that's not going to be the case in a
multi player match yeah but in a game
like titanfall where you have unions
spawning that makes the battles feel
bigger we can like shred your way
through ten stormtroopers and feel like
a badass do you think they're gonna do
that I don't know I think that that
would be cool if they grabbed really
cool I mean I don't know what else you
feel that a battlefield as you get in
the massive action game rusian I mean
God no one wants this is the big the
player cap is 40 it's gonna be 20 verses
20 and so depending on the map size you
know that could that can thin out or
that can feel crowded it all depends on
how they do that but it would be cool to
see some minions how do you write I mean
I will you can do co-op right just you
and a buddy I guess the AI so maybe
that's what ever is AI in there too
which is going to because that was yeah
so presumably like why else would they
have done that yeah maybe just pack up a
little bit more of a motala field I
don't know guess I'll have to wait and
see III I imagine is when we'll see more
of stars bow from no duh Robin Chris
thank you very much for reporting